ein Zalando Kunde hat sich diese Hose
bestellt sie dann allerdings nur mit
einem Stern bewertet mit der Begründung
Hose ist in Öffentlichkeit gerissen
überweist mir bitte 20 € für meine
verloren gegangene Ehre und damit
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
Episode dumme Google Bewertungen mit
Luca das bin ich
der aber auch sonst hier wird sich
dieser Schuh bestellt der auch mit fünf
Sternen bewertet wurde und mit der
Begründung versehen wurde muschalah
haben du die Lava damit steht gerei
perfekt er hat so bombe bekommen
hier wird sich wieder ein Schuh bestellt
der mit fünf Sterne bewertet wurde und
diesmal lautet die Begründung hat den
Schuh in Club angehabt habe mir Vanessa
geklärt aber die olle hat auf Schuhe
gekotzt aber Roller ging gut ab deswegen
ballert der Schuh böse bei der nächsten
Rezension wurde eine Gärtnerei bewertet
und der Typ hat ihm drei Sterne gegeben
und das mit der Begründung der Typ hat
meine Frau gebumst das geht gar nicht
seine Arbeit hatte dagegen gut
ausgefüllt deshalb drei Sterne ja man
muss halt Prioritäten setzen hier geht
es um das Wachsmuseum Madame Tussaud in
Berlin wo halt übel viele Wachsfiguren
rumstehen da wurde Wladimir Putin Angela
Merkel Justin Bieber bekannte
Persönlichkeiten einfach in Wachs nach
geformt eine Person hat da bewertet war
mir persönlich zu viel wachsen
als nächstes wird der rein bewertet
warum kann man den Fluss bewerten
der kann ja nicht mal dann was ändern
wenn man sagt dass das und das ist blöd
auf jeden Fall wird der Rhein hier mit
einem Stern bewertet und die Person hat
die Begründung angegeben ich finde der
Fluss fließt in die falsche Richtung er
gibt für mich so keinen Sinn
wie soll der denn in andere Richtung
fließen
alle Flüsse fließen noch ins Meer
soll soll er dann auch raushalten
anstatt rein oder
ja tatsächlich wieder eine Bewertung für
den Rhein der hat einfach mehr Google
Bewertung als ich auch wieder mit einem
Stern bewertet schmeckt nicht nach Bier
also ein Stern bro
scheiß drauf Daniel eine Kette gekauft
und dazu geschrieben habe es für meinen
siebenjährigen Sohn gekauft damit er in
der Volksschule angeben kann das wäre
reich sind und es klappt er hat mehr
Mädels am Start als ich erstmal warum
geht denn siebenjähriges Kind auf eine
Volksschule
was ist das Bruder und zweitens der
Daniel sagt dort dass ein siebenjähriger
Sohn mehr Mädels am Stadthalle als er
selbst
Bro willst du Grundschülerinnen am Start
haben oder was wollen wir nun zum
schiefen Turm von Pisa warum ist er
eigentlich schief
Sandra weil letztes Jahr dieses Bild
hier hochgeladen
der caption ich grüße Laser Luca
habe ich dann auch erstmal zurück
gegrüßt oder so wurde der schiefe Turm
von Pisa auch bewertet und zwar mit
einem Stern mit der Begründung da ich
Angst hatte dass der Turm gleich auf
mich kippt habe ich mein Bier
verschüttet warum dreht sich jede zweite
Bewertung um Bier wollen wir nun
allerdings zu einer Bewertung für die
Polizei Bremerhaven
ich dachte früher einfach das
Bremerhaven der Hafen von Bremen wäre
wie unkreativ kann man sein auf jeden
Fall wurde die Polizei dort mit einem
Stern bewertet denn musste in eine
Ausrichtung sein und durfte nicht mehr
meine Chicken Nuggets fertig essen als
ich wieder raus kam waren meine Chicken
Nuggets kalt und durfte sie immer noch
nicht essen und das finde ich schade
weil ich habe dafür Geld ausgegeben da
können wir tatsächlich gerade mal eine
Schweigeminute für einlegen
hier wurde der Matrix club in Berlin
bewertet und zwar mit einem Stern
kann es sein dass du dumm bist ich bin
besoffen ich sehe nichts holt mich
jemand ab
ist an sich eine gute Taktik
nee es ist eigentlich nicht diese Person
nicht rein
er hat den Club auf jeden Fall mit einem
Stern bewertet mit der Begründung hätte
der Türsteher seine Hausaufgaben damals
genauso ernst genommen wie seine
Türsteher aus Hilfstätigkeit wäre er
jetzt ja
boah das ist ein krasser Diss
aber irgendwie ist auch ein Kompliment
aber es ist auch ein Diss es ist es ist
beides gleichzeitig hier hat eine Person
die anonym bleiben möchte das Essen mit
einem Stern nur bewertet die Lieferung
allerdings mit vier und hat dazu
geschrieben Lebensmittelvergiftung hat
aber gut geschmeckt muss man halt
abwägen ja
warum denkt man warum kommentiere ich
die Sachen eigentlich ich kann euch doch
theoretisch einfach die Sachen
raussuchen und Vorlesen das wäre doch
viel einfacher also muss ich immer einen
Kommentar dazu ablassen
so wie die Person die die
Lebensmittelvergiftung hatte dann
nachher auf der Toilette auch was
abgelassen hat
hier wurde der Atlantische Ozean
bewertet warum
genau sie mit dem rein warum bewertest
du wolltest in Ruhe baden gehen aber
dann kam so eine Welle und hat mir
völlig versalzenes Wasser in die Augen
geschüttet bitte das Wasser möglichst
mit Chlor versetzen danke ja ich glaube
der Arbeiten die vom Atlantik schon dran
hier wurde die Domino's Pizza in
Buxtehude bewertet der käserrand
schmeckt nach Arschritze
okay
vielleicht hast du in deine Finger
gebissen
hier wurde das Berliner Tor bewertet
heißt das nicht Brandenburger Tor
oder bin ich gerade ein kompletter
Kulturbahnhof und es sind zwei
verschiedene Sachen ich habe auch egal
hat auf jeden Fall geschrieben
Drecksloch da hat mich meine Ex
als wäre das Tor das dafür kann
Berliner Tor
ja das haben die Hertha Fans aber auch
nicht so viel gesehen diese Sonne
Personal war sehr freundlich Essen war
toll aber die Parkplätze waren etwas
kleiner als der europäische Durchschnitt
EU-Norm gibt bei Parkplätzen 2,75 Meter
Mindestbreite vor bei diesem McDonald's
allerdings habe ich nachgemessen und zu
meinem Bedauern festgestellt dass die
Parkplatz breite lediglich zwei Meter 60
betrug daher meine ein Stern Bewertung
liebe Grüße wenigstens
liebe Grüße dagelassen die wurde eine
Justizvollzugsanstalt in München
bewertet und jemand hat geschrieben hat
Spaß gemacht waren wirklich 10 tolle
Jahre aber leider wurde ich
rausgeschmissen Mensch ich glaube bei
Gefängnissen ist es echt der einzige Ort
wo man sich darüber freut Hausverbot zu
bekommen und rausgeschmissen zu werden
hier wurde die Nordsee bewährt ich
jemand hat der Nordsee hier auf jeden
Fall nur einen Stern gegeben und das
ganze begründet mit voller Rheinfall
fahr mal an die Nordsee haben sie gesagt
Anreise permarspan war schon die totale
Katastrophe ja anstatt Sandstrand gab es
einen Grashügel hinter dem die ach so
tolle Nordsee sein sollte von wegen der
Schlammwüste von See nicht zu sehen
direkt zurück zum Hauptbahnhof und nach
Hause gefahren Hotel zwei Wochen umsonst
bezahlt Beschwerden bei Nordsee
Tourismus keine Reaktion nie wieder ja
was sollen die da auch sagen hier wurde
das Brandenburger Tor in Berlin bewertet
und zwar auch mit nur einem Stern denn
fünf Gründe wurden angegeben das Tor
steht gar nicht in Brandenburg das Tor
ist eher ein Durchgang das Tor lässt
sich nicht schließen davor ist der Platz
des 18 März der ist aber gar nicht wenn
man im Juli durchgeht und auf der
anderen Seite ist der Pariser Platz der
auch nicht in Paris ist das ist wirklich
eine absolute Mogelpackung der in Berlin
bei der nächsten Rezension hat oh
es war sehr lecker aber ziemlich kleine
Kugeln ich habe auch kleine Kugeln
auf jeden Fall hat der Inhaber dann
geantwortet und hat geschrieben freut
uns dass es Ihnen geschmeckt hat leider
werden sie den Geschmack aufgrund ihres
geschäftsbedingten bedingt die die haben
Hausverbot
sag mal wen grüße ich hier eigentlich
immer bei der nächsten Rezension hat der
liebe Tobi eine Pizzeria mit einem Stern
bewertet denn 18 Euro Bestellwert nach
Neuhausen und mich nicht mitnehmen
können obwohl man so oder so fährt
keinen Sinn ein Stern dafür er wollte
also das System dribbeln und hat sich
gedacht hey ich bin hier gerade an einem
Ort war wahrscheinlich gerade auf einer
Party und hier ist noch eine Pizzeria
ich könnte zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe
schlagen ich bestelle mir eine Pizza
nach Hause und der Typ soll mich direkt
mitnehmen geht aber nicht denn Tobi wie
wir die bereits erklärt haben dürfen wir
Dich nicht von A nach B fahren da wir
keinen Personenbeförderungsschein haben
wenn du das nächste Mal auf der Suche
nach einem billigen Taxi bist versuchst
auch bei einem Taxiunternehmen nicht bei
einer Pizzeria da haben wir wieder
Deutschland am Start ne
das ist lustig weil Deutschland
[Applaus]